it's spooky season and that means it's
time for some halloween games
if you're an xbox live gold member who
wants to grab some games as a free treat
good news the games with gold lineup for
october has been announced
here's what's coming in the new month
first up on xbox one is slay away camp
butcher's cut this is actually a puzzle
game where you take control of the evil
skull face
you'll solve puzzles to torture the camp
counselors and other victims
as you'd expect with classic 80s horror
you've got all month to puzzle through
it
since sleighaway camp will be available
for all of october
for a more traditional horror experience
xbox one is also getting made of skirv
based on welsh folklore this puts you in
a creepy hotel where you'll have to use
stealth to escape the quiet ones cult
and they're all about using their
heightened sense of hearing to track you
down
made of skir will be available from
october 16th through november
15th now don't tune out just yet these
360 games are backwards compatible for
you xbox
one players too the first of these is
not scary but it is a cult classic
action adventure
sphynx and the cursed mummy sphynx and
you guessed it the mummy can use all
sorts of special powers to explore the
world
collect stolen crowns and defeat the
evil egyptian gods set
sphynx will be available to download
from october 1st through the 15th
finally there's costume quest it's not
scary either
but it is a cutesy rpg from double fine
featuring kids who power up via
halloween costumes
you can grow your party as you explore
the neighborhood and complete quests
it'll be available to download from
october 16th through the 31st
and those are your free games with gold
for october 2020
remember that you can always check out
gameplay clips and reviews for these
titles on gamespot
and stay tuned as we report on the new
games with gold lineup every month
[Music]
you